welcome to GK Essentials where we
explore Basics and useful tips for
getting up and running on gke
[Music]
ing units or tpus are chips that Google
created to speed up machine learning
tasks tpus make machine learning model
work more efficiently by using Hardware
that is purpose built to accelerate ml
computation patterns for example matrix
multiplication or communication amongst
workers in a cluster tpus also have
built-in high bandwidth memory this
allows it to run even the biggest and
most demanding models a keep your
training supercomputer features hundreds
of TPU chips connected together with a
high speed chip to chip interconnect
called ICI ICI links coupled with TPU
software stack allows you to scale your
workload from one chip to much larger
scale with ease based on your workload
you can choose to create a specified
subset of this super computer as
instances referred to as TPU slice
you can use a single TPU slice or even
multiple TPU slices to accelerate your
large-scale training jobs or use smaller
slice shapes down to a single VM with a
single chip for inference Google Cloud
tpus are highly cost efficient for
training of large language models Vision
Transformer based architecture diffusion
based generative models and
recommendation systems however until now
orchestrating large-scale ai workload
with Cloud tpus have been a cumbersome
process
users have to perform a significant
amount of manual work to handle failure
logging monitoring and other basic
operations
We End Hardware concerns and we are here
to help
with the announcement of cloud tpus in
Google kubernetes engine we are
providing the much anticipated support
for gke for cloud TPU V4 and the latest
field generation Cloud TPU v5e with this
it will be easier than ever to develop
and manage large-scale AI workloads on
cloud kpus cloud tpus in gke combine the
price to Performance of Google's custom
design tpus with the power of GK this
means you can use the Simplicity of gke
to run your AI workloads and take
advantage of GK features like Auto
scaling Auto provisioning auto repair
and auto upgrade to ease the burden of
day 2 operations and manage your
resources more efficiently
you can also combine the power of tpus
and GK ecosystems using tools like
weights and baths is launch and manage
services for Prometheus with tpus in GK
if you are already using kubernetes to
run your web stateless State full batch
or other workloads you already know how
great it is to have a single platform to
manage everything now with the general
availability of cloud tpus on gke you
can get all the same benefits for your
AI workloads Cloud TPU node pools can be
Auto provisioned and auto scale so you
only use the resources you need and
never have to worry about over or under
provisioning and you can choose between
on-demand spot and Reserve Cloud TP
instances to fit your budget and
workload needs GK node pool groups
compute resources that are managed by
kubernetes to schedule workloads on
single host TPU slice load pools can
scale like normal loadables a TPU slice
is an intermitted group of one or more
TPU devices a TPU device is another name
for a single TPU VM or host for teamview
V4 this is a V4 by 8 which has 8 tensor
core 4 chips and the topology of Two by
Two by one
TPU topology refers to how the tpus are
connected together
tpus can be connected in different ways
based on application needs a multi-host
TPU slice is a single Atomic unit that
is if any of the TPU devices within the
node group fails the entire slice cannot
be used
a multi-hosted view slice also can be
Auto scaled after provisioning
the TPU chips in the slice are
interconnected in a certain physical
mesh defined by the topology therefore a
multi-host TPU slice in gke is
represented with a single Atomic
kubernetes node form for example a TPU
v432 has a topology of 2 by 2 by 4.
meaning that there are four TPU devices
connected with ispit interconnect
each device has 4 TPU chips each chip
has two tensor cores Q is an open source
project started by the kubernetes batch
working group for fair sharing and quota
management for batch and ML workloads
and kubernetes you can use Q for
scheduling jobs on TPU notes TPU logs in
GK are automatically collected by Cloud
logging and available in log Explorer
you can write your log to standard error
and standard out
you can also forward these logs to Pub
sub cloud storage bigquery or any other
third-party platform this has generally
been a challenging task in TPU workloads
a workloading TPU is spread across many
VMS a centralized logging system will
help speed up the finding and debugging
of potential issues errors are
automatically detected in logs and
visualized as histograms to give a view
of historical frequency this lets you
quickly identify common problems and the
history of the error
many metrics are exported to Cloud
monitor like duty cycle which indicates
percent of time the TPU is being
actively utilized this helps determine
the efficiency of our tpe usage these
metrics can also be used to configure
kubernetes horizontal Auto scaling TPU
v5e is our latest offering in our TPU AI
supercomputer family Cloud TPU v5d is
designed to enable the next generation
of AI applications it's our most cost
efficient scalable and versatile Cloud
TPU air acceleration platform today TPU
v5b offers up to two times higher
training performance and up to 2.5 times
inverse performance per dollar compared
to TPU V4 for lens and generative AI
model
in this video we talked about how TPU
and GK work together to give you the
power to build the AML platform of the
future
learn more about tpus and dke click the
links in the description below
[Music]